[Music]
one of the strong benefits of meditation
generally has to do with you know the
ordinary ways in which we suffer
depression anxiety the oxd of life it
turns out that meditation generally
makes people feel more positively and
helps diminish anxiety but it becomes
particularly powerful when it's combined
with a psychotherapy the way this is
usually done is with mindfulness on the
one hand and what's called cognitive
therapy on the other mindfulness allows
us to shift our relationship to our
experience instead of getting sucked
into our emotions or our thoughts which
is what happens when we're depressed or
anxious we see them as those thoughts
again all those feelings again
and that disempowers them there's
actually research at UCLA that shows
when you can name that feeling oh I'm
feeling depressed again you have shifted
the activity levels neurologically in
the part of the brain which is depressed
to the part of the brain which notices
which is aware of the prefrontal cortex
and that diminishes the depression and
enhances your ability to be able to
understand it or to see it as just a
feeling so if you combine that ability
with cognitive therapy cognitive therapy
helps you talk back to your thoughts
it's the basic realization and cognitive
therapy is I don't have to believe my
thoughts this is extremely important in
people with chronic anxiety or chronic
depression because it's our thoughts
that trigger the anxiety that triggered
the depression you know the depressive
thoughts are classic I'm no good my life
is worthless whatever it is those
thoughts actually make us depressed so
if you use mindfulness based cognitive
therapy on the one hand you can see oh
there's that thought again on the other
hand cognitive therapy lets you talk
back to that thought oh I'm not so
worthless I've done some pretty good
things in my life
they're people who love me whatever it
may be you can develop a habit of not
letting those thoughts take you over but
countering them with actual evidence
from your life that says though they're
not true I don't have to believe them
and that is very relieving the first
study that used mindful space cognitive
therapy with depression I was a pretty
spectacular it was done at Oxford
University and it was done with people
whose depression is so severe that
nothing helps no medication helps
electroshock doesn't help you no
medicine psychiatry doesn't know what to
do people get depressed very deeply they
recover and then they get depressed
again so with that group they use
mindfulness based cognitive therapy they
found that it cut the rate of relapse of
having depression again by 50% if this
were a drug some pharmaceutical company
would be making billions of dollars but
it's not a drug it's it's free basically
so mindfulness based cognitive therapy
works very well for depression better
design studies afterwards show that it
was 50% but still the impact is palpable
and it turns out that mindfulness and
other meditations particularly combined
with cognitive therapy work just as well
for anxiety or depression as the
medications do but they don't have those
side effects
[Music]
you